EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR ARE YOU
THERE. MISS ALICE THIS IS THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE LIKE TO CALL
TO ORDER THE ASSEMBLY UTILITIES
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE. OF FIRST
OF ALL I'D LIKE TO- WELCOME OUR
MEMBERS TO THIS COMMITTEE IT
ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME A DOCTOR
WOULD- WHO IS- SITTING AND-
TODAY AS WELL AS LAURA
FRIEDMAN- WHO IS ALSO BEEN
APPOINTED TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR
TODAY'S MEETING. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF THE STAFF THAT
HAVE MADE A RETURN TO THE
CAPITAL. TO HEAR BILLS POSSIBLE.
DUE TO THE CURRENT STAY AT HOME
ORDER. WE'RE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE NAME HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL- SO WE ARE ABLE TO
HAVE LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
HEARING. THE HEARING IN PERSON
WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESSES TO TESTIMONY TO
GIVE TESTIMONY TODAY. TODAY IN
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER WE'RE HAVING
TO PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. IN THIS SPACE WE CAN
NLY ACCOMMODATE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF MEMBERS A MINIMUM
CONTENT IN A STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEET YEAH SOWE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY. IN THIS
HEARING. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE RIVER IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL. PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING TO RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING.
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS AREA CODE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING MAN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF ANY YOUR CALL A
MAN. ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCASTING YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOUR MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE IT
WOULD NEED TO MEET YOURSELF
INTO YOUR CALL. TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING A PROBLEM WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO EIGHT THREE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. WE ALL
FACE. MEMBERS F YOU WOULD LIKE
TO RESPOND TO A ROLL CALL. ASK
A QUESTION OR PROVIDE COMMENT.
YOU WILL NEED TO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES SO STAFF CAN
ACTIVATED WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. ALSO
PLEASE STAND UP AND FACE THE
MICROPHONE WHILE SPEAKING TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
AND CAN BE RECORD. WE WILL HEAR
ONE BILL TODAY. SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTY WAS PULLED AT THE
AUTHOR'S REQUEST AND THE
COMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AROUND HIS BILL. TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL
FOR EACH SIDE. TO DATE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES PLEASE
BRIEFLY STATE YOUR NAME
POSITION AN AFFILIATION IF ANY.
AND NOW WILL LAST THE COMMITTEE
STAFF TO CALL THE ROLL.
PRESIDENT. PATTERSON PRESIDENT
FREEDMAN. FRIEDMAN PRESIDENT
CARILLO CREO PRESENT CHEN. CHEN
PRESIDENT CUNNINGHAM. CUTTING
HIM HERE EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE
CRISTINA GARCIA AND WHETHER
GARCIA. MAYES MAYES PRESIDENT
MURATSUCHI WHERE THIRTY PRESENT
WOULD. WOULD PRESIDENT RAY S.
REYES PRESENT SANTIAGO. TING
TANK PRESENT. OUR FIRST BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA ON PUBLIC UTILITIES
CORPORATION WITH IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES ASSEMBLYMEMBER THE
FORESHORES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
TO THE COMMITTEE THE FIRST OF
WHAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
IN TWO YEARS COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR YOUR KIND ATTENTION. I WORK
WITH MY TEAM ON THIS BILL.
MEMBERS. PICKING UP WHAT YOU
PUT DOWN A ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH
FURTHER PROTECT. ENERGY GAS
CONSUMPTION DATA FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO NOW MORE THAN
EVER NEED TO DESERVED. AND
NEEDED TO FEEL SAFE AT HOME
WHEN YOU TO SETTLE INTO THE
SERVICES PROVIDED BY UTILITIES-
I WILL SKIP THE LIGHT OF MY
COMMENTS AND PICKING UP. AGAIN
THE MESSAGE YOU'RE SENDING THIS
CHAIRMAN I DO HAVE A WITNESS
WITH ME- THIS MORNING- ACTUALLY
SALAS IS AN ATTORNEY- WITH THE
YOU TO UTILITY REFORM NETWORK
TURN- I WOULD ASK HER TO. BE
ABLE TO GIVE HER TESTIMONY IN
AN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
WOULD COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU A PHONE MODERATOR ACTUALLY
SALAS. WITH UTILITY. REFORM
NETWORK- YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. HER LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AND
DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE MEMBER
IT IS AN HONOR TO SPEAK BEFORE
YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS ASHLEY
SALAS I HAVE BEEN A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH THE TOLL REFORM
THAT WORK FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS. I AM BASED IN SAN DIEGO
WHERE I HAVE BEEN A LIFELONG
RESIDENT. TURN ADVOCATES FOR
UTILITY COSTS FOR PROTECTION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
ON PRIVACY ISSUES. WHEN THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES THE
GENIE SO HOW ANDERSON SB
JEANNIE START ROLLING OUT MARK
LEADERS TO RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL INFRINGEMENT ON
CALIFORNIANS PRIVACY RIGHT.
TURN ALLOCATED FOR THE CQC TO
REQUIRE THE ENERGY UTILITY
THREE QUIRK WHO IF ANYONE WAS
REQUESTING THEIR CUSTOMER DATA.
THESE TRANSPARENCY REPORTS
REVEALED THAT FEDERAL AGENCIES
REQUEST THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA ENERGY UTILITIES
CUSTOMER DATA. THE BOOK OF
WHICH ARE QUITE GOOD ABOUT SB
JEANNIE CUSTOMER. YES SB
JEANNIE HOW THE SMALLEST
CUSTOMER BASE OF ALL THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
SERVING ONLY ONE OUT OF EVERY
SEVENTEEN I OWE YOU CUSTOMER.
THE TRANSPARENCY QUIRK ALSO
SHOW THAT IMMIGRATION CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT IN PARTICULAR
DEMAND MORE CUSTOMER
INFORMATION FROM SB GENE BUT
FROM PEKING AND STILL CAL
EDISON COMBINE. THIS IS JACK
BUT I IS USING A LOOPHOLE IN
THE CURRENT LAW IN ORDER TO A
PAYING CUSTOMER DATA IN BORDER
AREAS. IF YOU OWN
ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENAS
INSTEAD OF SECURING A JUDICIAL
WARRANT. THIS HARASSMENT CAN
DISCOURAGE MEMBERS OF OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES FROM
OBTAINING UTILITY SERVICES.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
FEAR FOR THEIR PRIVACY IS A
NEED TO ESTABLISH POTENTIAL
ENERGY. TURN WORK WITH PARTNER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE
ENERGY SERVICES. AND YOU
PRIVACY WITH REGARD TO THE
SERVICES. CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
NOT BE DISSUADED FROM
ESTABLISHING ESSENTIAL ENERGY
UTILITY SERVICES OUT OF FEAR
THAT I WILL CHANGE THEIR
CUSTOMER DATA. THEREFORE TURNED
URGES YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. DO WE HAVE ANY%
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN BACK OF
THE HAMBER FLOOR IN BACK OF
THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN BACK OF THE
CHAMBER OR ON THE FLOOR SEEING
NONE. DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
OTHER TWEETERS AND STATED
EARLIER THAN NINE OUR PHONE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YES WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
LINE Q. ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE JUST TO
HEAR YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION THANK YOU. MORNING
TERRY MEMBERS AND CHAIR OF
ERROR WITH A CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER NINE AGAIN
THAT IS LINE NUMBER NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ARIANNA POSSIBLE
WOULD BE A FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THE TWO
I KNOW WE HAVE O ONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE ON THE PHONE PLEASE
CONTINUE BROWN MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. FOR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD. YOU HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. FOUR FOUR MODERATED
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE
TWEETERS. IF YOU ARE A TWEENER
I YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD AGAIN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. YOU HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE-
PROCEED. THANK YOU I WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
BILL. SEVEN ARRESTS. I'M SORRY.
YES NO JUST STAND IN THE NEWS
OR- AFTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SOMEONE NUMBER GLORIA FOR
PRESENTING THIS AYE AYE I KNOW
THIS WAS SAID IN THE TESTIMONY
FROM THE- WITNESS FROM THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK. BUT
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT. IN THEIR
LETTER THEY INDICATE ICE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO EXPLOIT A LOOPHOLE
IN THE LAW WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
ISSUE THEIR OWN ADMINISTRATIVE
SUBPOENAS INSTEAD OF HAVING TO
SECURE JUDICIAL AUTHORITY.
USING THIS LOOPHOLE ICE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO DEMONSTRATE TO A
JUDGE THAT THEIR DEMANDS ARE
RELATED TO IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS. OR EVEN
JUSTIFIED. IT'S CLEAR THAT
DURING THESE TIMES OF
UNCERTAINTY OR DON'T DOCUMENTED
FAMILIES ARE SUFFERING FAR MORE
THAN THEIR PEERS. WE CANNOT LET
THIS PANDEMIC BLINDERS FROM THE
ON GOING ISSUES THEY HAVE
SUFFERED FOR WAY TOO LONG AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA FOR OFFERING THIS
MEASURE. AND FOR SERVING THE
MUCH NEEDED PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
FOR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. THE OTHER MEMBERS NAME.
OKAY SCRIPT AND THEN. A STRANGE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I JUST
WANTED TO SAY AND A COUPLE OF
MY COLLEAGUES SENTIMENTS I
THINK THE GREAT BILL AND ON THE
TIME IS RIGHT I'D LOVE TO
COOPER. THE CANNELLA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR BRING IN THE BILL
FORWARD AND I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT IN ADDITION TO THE GOAL OF
THE BILL I THINK IT SETS FORTH
A VERY IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE
THAT'S GENERALLY TRUE WHICH IS
THAT THE TO GET BEFORE PEOPLE'S
PRIVATE. SO THAT YOU FOR THE
BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO. TODAY
ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IT'S VERY GOOD
BILL AND WE'RE PROUD TO BE ABLE
TO RECOMMEND IT AS A DO PASS-
DIRECTLY TO THE FLOOR WE HAVE A
MOTION IT'S BEEN SECONDED ROLL
CALL THE MOTION. I'M SORRY
ALLEGE ELECTRICAL. NOT A COPY
OUT OF A WIN TODAY THE CHAIRMAN
SAID I JUST APPRECIATION TO YOU
AND TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE INSPECTS AFTER I'VE
OF. THANK YOU. LOCAL MOTION TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR HOLDEN HI.
HOLDEN I PATTERSON. NOT VOTING
FREEDMAN. CORREO CARILLO I CHEN.
NOT VOTING CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN MAKE MEN
I CRISTINA GARCIA MEDINA GARCIA
I EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
I MAYES. MAYES I MURATSUCHI
YOUR SU CHI I WOULD WOOD I
RAMOS. REYES I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE TING. TING I.
TWELVE TWELVE VOTES HI THE BILL
HAS TWELVE BOASTED PASSES OUT
OF COMMITTEE ALL MEMBERS WHO
VOTED- IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIS
MEETING AFTER.